hi guys dr. Berg here in this video I want to
talk about an interesting vitamin b1 and it's
deficiencies this is very common and it's quite
interesting because it's actually a helper factor
or a helper vitamin in three main enzymes that
have to do with carbohydrates now when someone
switches over to a ketogenic diet the whole
mechanism of burning fat in the mitochondria
it needs a lot of b1 so you also need b1 in fat
metabolism as well so here are the symptoms number
one nervous energy like this buildup of nervous
energy like you're going to explode or you're just
very restless you can't relax okay that's number
one number two edema or swelling in your calf when
you have enough b1 you don't accumulate fluid okay
b1 also is connected to the heart as well numbness
tingling in the hands or feet that relates to
diabetes simply because b1 is involved in the
production of myelin the surrounding covering of
the nerves so when you don't have b1 because you
had too much sugar it strips off that you start
having neurological problems okay number four
increase heart rate now the calcium also keeps
the heart in check but also be one does as well
probably because the electrical connection to the
heart number five restless legs now you're trying
to sleep in your pound your legs I had this
problem for years I would literally get up in
the middle of the night and pound my legs and go
exercise to try to get this energy out because of
this driving me nuts so what's happening is you
have this retention of lactic acid like after a
workout you're going to have less lactic acid and
it's going to actually keep the energy into the
lower part of the legs that's a b1 deficiency b1
helps release that lactic acid it can also improve
recovery time after exercise next one seasickness
or car sickness if you have that take more b1 that
will help you nightmares if you have nightmares
or vivid dreams or your kids have that nightmares
give them vitamin b1 that is the solution air
hunger so let's say your can't get enough air
now it could be that your pH is too acid or like
an lactic acidosis or high lactic acid or it could
be that you're just b1 deficient okay so another
remedy for that so now what causes b1 deficiencies
number one sugar okay hidden sugars refined grains
in sugars like juice things like that alcohol will
do it liver damage like cirrhosis or a fatty
liver because you need the liver to metabolize
a lot of these B vitamins stress will deplete
b1 caffeine will do it that would be like in
tea as well too much of it birth control pills
anti acids okay so what is a solution number
one cut the sugar out the grains the alcohol
stress right cut down the caffeine and add
nutritional yeast to the diet make sure that's
unfortified nutritional yeast because they put
synthetic vitamins in there I don't recommend
taking synthetic vitamins unless you're doing
a detox but as a maintenance get the natural
ones or concentrated nutritional yeast thanks
for watching hey if you haven't already subscribed
press this little button down below okay thanks